RACHEL SHEARER: All right.
Welcome everybody.
My name's Rachel Shearer.
This is Dominic Mazzoni
and Charles Chen.
And we're here today to talk
about advancing accessibility
for the Web, as I advance
my slides.
So, last year Dominic and I gave
a talk at Google I/O on
web accessibility.
We focused on basic tips, like
making sure you have all
attributes on your images, and
making sure that your buttons
are focusable.
How many of you were there
at that talk last year?
Oh, wow.
That's a lot of you.
For those of you who weren't
there, this is a photo of--
mid-talk, I'm assuming--
me and Dominic.
We're laughing.
We're having a good time.
This year both of us are back.
But this year we also
have Charles Chen.
And we are so excited that
Charles is here that one of us
edited him into the photo
from last year.
I'm not going to say which one
of us it was that did that.
Because it's not necessarily
the best editing
job you've ever seen.
Anyway this year we decided
to go into high gear.
Because we have Charles.
We're all here.
We're very excited.
We wanted to focus on some new
tools, techniques, and APIs
that can really help you push
the boundaries of what's
possible in terms
of accessibility
inside your web apps.
We're hoping that you leave
today inspired to go out and
build something really great,
and build something really
usable for users with
special needs.
So now I'm going to give you a
quick overview of what we're
going to talk about today.
First I'm going to jump into
testing for accessibility, and
show you two tools that can
really help you find and
eliminate accessibility errors
in your apps, the
Accessibility Developer
Tools and ChromeVox.
Next, Dominic is going to talk
about Advanced Screen Reader
Accessibility.
And he's going to show two
examples of accessible
editors, an accessible text
editor, and an accessible
terminal emulator.
Next, Charles is going to
introduce ChromeVox
extensions.
He's going to show off the
PlusVox ChromeVox Extension,
which is an extension for
Power Google+ users.
Finally Dominic is going
to come back.
And he's going to talk about his
favorite Chrome APIs, like
APIs for low vision, and
APIs for speech.
So that's going to
be really great.
Now that I've told you what you
can expect to hear from us
over the next hour, 50 minutes,
or so, I'm going to
start right off and talk
about testing.
How you can find accessibility
errors in your apps?
So, all of us on stage
are web developers.
But we also work with other
web developers at Google.
And over the years we've
discovered a few things that
we'd like to share
with you today.
The first is a fundamentally
optimistic point.
Many web apps can be made
accessible to users with
special needs.
And I'd even go so far as to
say most web apps are not
actually fundamentally
inaccessible.
Assistive technology is
improving and can better
handle rich, interactive,
dynamic apps.
And techniques from HTML5 and
ARIA can help you bridge the
gap and get your app looking
really good.
But the problem is simple
errors are causing huge
problems for users.
These are simple errors like not
labeling your form fields
or not having controls be
keyboard focusable.
These kinds of absurdly simple
errors can make apps
completely unusable to users
of assistive technology.
And so you might say to yourself
if these are simple
errors, why aren't we
testing for them?
It should be easy to test
for these errors.
Well at Google, we've found that
existing accessibility
testing tools weren't
meeting our needs.
Many of them recommend older
techniques, like accesskey,
longdesc, or noscript, instead
of recommending newer
alternatives from
ARIA or HTML5.
Some existing accessibility
testing tools assume that your
web app is like a document, and
it's a list of links or
static text.
And they don't actually support
the rich, dynamic web
applications that we're here at
I/O to learn how to build.
Some existing accessibility
tools just don't integrate
well with your existing
workflows as a developer.
They might require you to
install a completely new
desktop app to test
for accessibility.
And some accessibility
testing tools only
work well on one platform.
Or they assume that your
users are using
a particular platform.
And at Google, we realize that a
lot of the developers around
us are spending a lot of time in
the Chrome Developer Tools.
So why not put the Accessibility
Testing Tools
right inside the Chrome
Developer Tools where people
are spending a lot
of their time.
So that's what we did.
We created the Accessibility
Developer Tools for Chrome.
It's a Chrome extension that
adds a special audit to your
Chrome Developer Tools that
allows you to check for
accessibility errors.
Some of the things that we
check for are things like
labels and alternative
content, keyboard
accessibility, ARIA, low vision
accessibility like
contrast ratio, and video
accessibility like the
presence of captions or fall
back content for video.
And these aren't really
complex errors.
These are simple errors.
We wanted to make sure that
our tool could confidently
highlight these errors and
explain to you the developer
what you could improve in your
app to make it better.
And the good news is that these
simple errors are often
the most simple for the
developer to fix.
And so we really thought that
by focusing on these errors,
we could focus on practical
web accessibility for
developers.
But--
I mean, we just launched
this two days ago.
So as time moves forward, we'll
definitely be increasing
the number of things we check
for in an effort to bring a
broader array of checks to the
Accessibility Developer Tools.
So now that I've talked about
that, I also want to highlight
another tool that you have in
your arsenal as a developer.
And that's ChromeVox.
We launched ChromeVox last year
at Google I/O. And it's a
Chrome Extension
Screen Reader.
So that means it's built using
JavaScript, HTML, and CSS.
You control it using
keyboard shortcuts.
And it interprets the page,
speaking using the Chrome Text
to Speech API.
And the great thing about
ChromeVox is that it
interprets the page just like
any other screen reader.
It speaks out loud the contents
of the screen in a
similar way to screen readers
like JAWS or NVDA.
But it has all the benefits of
being a Chrome extension,
which means it's easy to set up,
it's easy to use, and it
integrates right into
the browser.
So now that we know about the
Accessibility Developer Tools,
and we know we have ChromeVox,
how do we use the two together
to find and eliminate
accessibility
errors in our apps?
Well, I have a demo for you
to show you how you
can use them together.
This is a really simple
web form.
You can just enter your name in
the input field, click the
check box, click register.
And it adds you to
a mailing list.
So let's try running ChromeVox
on it and see what happens.
These are HTML5 slides.
And ChromeVox has been running
this entire time.
I'm just going to activate it
using keyboard shortcuts.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Enabling
spoken feedback.
RACHEL SHEARER: As you can see,
it put a little visual
cursor on the screen as to where
ChromeVox's focus is.
I'm just going to move down
through the form.
And we'll see what
ChromeVox says.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Enter
your name.
Article.
Edit text.
Yes, please add me to
your mailing list.
Clickable.
You may receive one
email per week.
Register now.
Done.
RACHEL SHEARER: So that
was a little fast.
Because it kind of just went
through the entire page.
Let's try and go through
them one at time.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Demo.
Heading to heading group.
Article.
Edit text.
RACHEL SHEARER: So you see
it just said, edit text.
There's more information
visually on this page.
It says enter your name.
But ChromeVox just
says edit text.
And if you can't see the screen,
you might not know
that you're supposed to do
something to this edit field.
I'm just tabbing through like
many users of screen readers
do, tabbing through the page
to try and figure out what
you're supposed to do.
Right now I'm not really sure.
Let's tab again and see if we
can get to that checkbox.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Register
now button.
RACHEL SHEARER: OK.
It skipped right over
the checkbox.
That's definitely a red flag.
There's something weird going
on with this form.
Maybe the checkbox
isn't focusable.
Maybe it's not a checkbox at all
and it's just an image of
a square that someone put on
the screen to try and look
like a checkbox.
There's a lot of different
things that could be going on.
But the good thing is we have
the Accessibility Developer
Tools to show us exactly
what the problems are.
I'm going to turn
ChromeVox off.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Disabling
spoken feedback.
RACHEL SHEARER: And I'm going
to open the Developer Tools
using another keyboard
shortcut.
All right.
So it's opened right up
into the Audits pane.
I've actually zoomed in a lot
so you guys can see it.
Can you in the back see
the Developer Tools?
Can you see the results?
Yes?
I'm going to assume
that's a yes.
So you see that I have a list
of audits that I can run.
And it includes accessibility.
So I'm going to uncheck
the other ones.
Hopefully you didn't come
to learn about webpage
performance.
Because you're going to be
disappointed during this talk.
I'm going to run the
Accessibility Audit.
And you'll see right away it
comes up with a slightly wonky
list of errors on the page.
There is red, severe errors.
There is yellow, warnings.
And there is green, tests that
either passed or weren't
applicable to this page.
There are so many errors on
this page, you might even
think that the person who wrote
this page maybe wrote it
on purpose to have a lot of
errors if you are a suspicious
person like me.
So let's just go through
these one at a time.
The first one is a severe error
that says controls and
media elements should
have labels.
So I'm going to open it up.
And you see it actually points
exactly at the element that
has the particular error.
So you can see it's kind of
highlighting this input field
up at the top.
Maybe I can make this go down
a little bit so you can see.
It's highlighting that
input field.
And it's just like
we suspected.
There's no label on
that input field.
And the neat thing is that you
can click on this link.
And it will open up in a new
window and show you exactly
what the problem was and
how you can fix it.
This is a wiki page on the
Developer site that we have.
And it goes through the ways
that you can fix this problem
and why your page was
highlighted as maybe having an
error here.
So this can be really helpful
if your developer was new to
accessibility.
I'm going to exit full screen,
go back here, and go back into
full screen.
So you can see that
that's a problem.
Let's go to the next one.
Elements with ARIA roles
must use a valid
non-abstract ARIA role.
And that's pointing at
this check box here.
If you're someone who's
memorized the ARIA spec like I
am, you would see immediately
that this ARIA role attribute
isn't right.
If says role=check instead
of role=checkbox.
If you aren't someone who's
memorized the ARIA spec, you
can click on this link and it
will tell you exactly what the
problem is.
Next we're going to warnings.
And these warnings are there.
And they're considered less
severe than the severe errors.
Because sometimes as a
developer, you might be
breaking these rules
on purpose.
Or you might be aware that
you're breaking these rules.
But it's serving a
larger purpose.
So that's why we've highlighted
these separately
from the most severe errors.
We're giving you more
information as a developer.
So the first one is elements
with onclick
handlers must be focusable.
And this is actually getting
to the root of the problem
with this checkbox.
There's an onclick handler.
But this is just a span.
It's not actually focusable.
There's no way to put keyboard
focus on this checkbox.
If we had used an input element,
like a regular native
HTML input element, then we
would have gotten keyboard
focus for free.
But we used a span.
And so there's actually no way
a keyboard-only user can put
focus on this checkbox.
So that's bad.
Let's look at the next one.
And this is actually one
of my favorite errors.
Text elements should have a
reasonable contrast ratio.
And it's pointing at this
fine print right here.
And probably you guys in
the back might not even
be able to see this.
Because it's actually written
in a very light grey text.
And this is not a high enough
contrast text for someone with
low vision to be able to see.
And so you can see it's
highlighting it.
And I can actually right click
on it and say Reveal an
Elements Panel to take me over
to the Elements panel and show
me where on the page
this text is.
If you look on the right hand
pane, there's something called
Accessibility Properties.
I can open that up.
And it actually calculated the
contrast ratio for me right
there in the Accessibility
properties.
It shows you what it thinks the
foreground color is, which
is this gray, shows
you the background
color, which is white.
And it's saying the contrast
ratio is 2.32.
It's got a little warning
sign next to it.
Because that contrast ratio is
actually not good enough for
many users with low vision.
So this is something
that's really neat.
A lot of accessibility
errors--
you could maybe look in the
DOM tree or look at the
Elements pane and kind of
figure out what's wrong.
But I can't calculate contrast
ratio just by looking at a
piece of text.
So this is where the
Accessibility Developer Tools
really helps you go the extra
mile and be able to figure out
some errors that might not be
obvious at first glance.
So let's go back into
the Audits pane.
And we've actually got
three more warnings.
And these ones are a little
bit more subtle
than the other warnings.
It's actually highlighting
links on the next slide.
And that's because the
Accessibility Developer Tools
is so smart that it actually
figured out a bug in the
slides themselves.
It's only showing one
slide at a time.
But it's actually loaded the
previous slide and the next
slide in the DOM.
And they're just hidden behind
this current slide.
And I think they did that for
smoothness purposes or to make
sure there wasn't any weird
gaps between slides.
But these links in the next
slide are still focusable.
If you're a keyboard only user,
and you can't use the
mouse, and you're tabbing around
this page, you'll end
up in the links on the
next slide even
though they're not visible.
And it's a subtle bug.
But it's still a bug
in the slides.
And so the Accessibility
Developer Tools is
highlighting it so that as the
developer, you can make the
decision that's best for you
about what you want to do in
this situation.
And the next tests at the bottom
are not applicable,
which means they weren't
run on this page.
So we don't have an ARIA
labeled by attribute.
And we're not using video.
So those tests don't
even matter.
And then we have one green
passing test at the bottom,
which is, images should
have an alt attribute.
So altogether I think I would
give this form maybe a C- or a
D+ in terms of accessibility.
Let's see if we can fix
one of these areas and
maybe raise our grade.
I'm going to right click on the
check box that didn't have
the right ARIA role, reveal it
in the Elements panel, and see
if I can fix it right now.
If I double click on the
attribute, I can just edit it
right inside the
Elements pane.
And I'm going to add the word
box to have ARIArole=checkbox,
which I know is the
right ARIA role.
And I hit Enter and go back
to the Audits pane.
And let's try running
this audit again.
Hit the Run button.
And you'll see that one of those
red errors disappeared.
And that's because I just
fixed that right now.
This is one of the really
powerful things about the
Developer Tools.
You can experiment with
different fixes right inside
the Developer Tools, run the
audit again, and see how your
fix either improved or
regressed your score.
And this takes a lot of time
out of the equation.
You can try out different
things right there.
You don't have to go back and
upload it to a server or
refresh the page or anything
like that.
You can try out different things
and find the solution
that works best for you.
OK.
So I'm not going to fix all
the rest of these errors.
We'll just have to leave
ourselves with a low grade.
I'm going to move on
to the next slide.
So I've showed you two tools
that you can add to your
arsenal to improve the way that
you find and eliminate
accessibility errors.
They're both no cost.
They're both open source.
And we really recommend that
you use them together.
ChromeVox is good to use.
Because it really gives you a
good idea for how an end user
might experience your page.
It can be difficult to
understand how someone who
can't see at all can use
a screen reader to
experience your app.
And ChromeVox can help you
understand a little bit what
they might be going through.
And the Accessibility Developer
Tools are great.
Because they lay it all out
in front of you-- what the
problems might be.
You can go in and try
out different fixes.
And you can see what works
and what doesn't work.
The Accessibility Developer
Tools was actually launched--
I think it was two days ago.
And it's on the Web Store.
ChromeVox, you can also get on
the Web Store or learn more
about it at chromevox.com.
And we have a Google Code site
for it, google-axs-chrom
e.code.google.com.
And I think the Accessibility
Developer Tools are also on
Google Code.
But I think we forgot
to add the link.
It's accessibility-de
veloper-tools.googlecode.com.
So now that you know how
to test your apps for
accessibility, I'm going to
bring Dominic on back to talk
about advanced accessibility
techniques.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: Thanks
very much, Rachel.
Yeah, I want to say one
more point about
those Developer Tools.
One of the things that
I love about them--
you might remember last year we
talked about ChromeShades.
I see this as the next evolution
of ChromeShades.
Because a normal extension that
is running in the page
that's just built using
JavaScript has some
limitations in terms of what
it's able to check.
For example, one of the most
common errors that I saw in
web applications was that
someone added an on click
handler to an element
on the page.
But it wasn't possible to access
that with a keyboard.
And for the longest time, I was
trying to figure out a way
that we could detect that
automatically, but without
needing to hack the browser or
use some other side loaded
technique or something.
With the possibility of
Developer Tools extensions,
we're able to sort of get behind
the DOM and access a
bunch of things that aren't
normally available from
JavaScript, like for example to
find out if an element has
a click handler, even if
it was added without
addEventListener or something
else like that.
So now that we have this
ability, a lot more subtle
accessibility errors
are now possible to
detect, which is great.
But what I want to move onto
now is the next step.
So you've gone through, and
you've taken your web
application, and you've fixed
all the simple errors.
So you don't have anything
which is unlabeled.
You don't have anything which
is impossible to access with
the keyboard.
But maybe you have some custom
controls or you have some
custom user interface, and just
doing the basics isn't
enough to meet the
needs of users.
So last year we talked about
a few examples of that.
We showed you how you can take
a pop up dialogue in HTML and
make that accessible.
We talked about how you can
build a custom slider.
And we talked about how you can
manage focus so that if
someone is using the keyboard to
move through your app, they
not only have a great experience
when using the
keyboard, but also assistive
technology like screen readers
and magnifiers are also doing
the right thing and giving
appropriate feedback.
Let me just give one
example of that.
If you're interested in more of
those techniques, you can
watch our talk from last year.
Or there's a webinar that Rachel
did that talks about
more of those techniques.
But let me give you
one example here.
I've got a ratings gadget.
There's like five stars here.
And I can click on one of them
and rate something like a
restaurant, or a cinema,
or something like that.
And this gadget is not
only able to be
used with the mouse.
But it's also keyboard
accessible.
And it gives appropriate
feedback to a screen reader.
And the way we've done that is
just by adding an ARIA role of
slider, and then ARIA valuemin,
valuemax, and valuenow.
And if you set those attributes
on an HTML element
and update them dynamically as
the element changes, and of
course you make sure that
you've implemented the
keyboard access, then that
element is going to give
appropriate feedback to
a screen reader user.
Just giving it a role of
slider and setting the
appropriate value means
the someone who is
using a screen reader--
they expect it to behave
like a slider.
Now this isn't a slider.
They'll still know that it's
maybe a star rating gadget.
But the point is it behaves
like a slider.
The semantic equivalent to
what this is is a slider.
So just if you have something
that's toggleable on a page,
it might be some other
type of control.
But conceptually it's
a checkbox.
In this case, we've decided that
conceptually this behaves
like a slider.
You can use the left and right
arrows to change things.
So let me turn on ChromeVox and
show you exactly what that
looks like.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Enabling
spoken feedback.
Show all [? download-- ?]
five stars.
Fantastic.
Slider five stars.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: So, it was
a bit repetitive there.
But you heard that it described
the slider.
And it said the word slider,
indicating that's the role.
And as I use the arrow keys
to change the value--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Four
stars, awesome.
Three stars, OK.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: It reads the
new value of the slider.
And all I needed was to update
these ARIA attributes.
So that's what we covered
last year.
And there's a bunch of other
examples like that.
You can build custom list
boxes and combo boxes.
And really tons of other custom
controls are really
just special cases of pretty
common user interface widgets
that users are already familiar
with in terms of
their semantics.
So it doesn't mean that you
should feel limited to
standard types of input controls
when you're building
your application.
It just means that you can
express them in terms of
semantics users are already
familiar with.
So no matter what type of
device-- if they're using
Braille, if they're using speech
output, if they need
the screen magnified for them,
they get all the information
they need in order
to work with it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Disabling
spoken feedback.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: So I'd like
to talk about something a
little bit new that I haven't
seen too many examples of out
there, and that's
text editors.
In last year I've seen a number
of websites that have
started to build custom
text editors.
And by custom, I mean instead
of something that's using a
native control like an input,
a text area, or content
editable, they're actually
building the whole experience
themselves.
And, in fact, at Google we
do this with Google Docs.
Google Docs does not use
content editable.
Everything is actually custom.
And that's really necessary
in order to provide a real
desktop-like experience for a
full featured word processor.
There are all sorts
of examples.
It could be some game where
you're filling something in.
It could be like a fancier email
program where instead of
just typing text into the To
field, you might be able to
have objects that you can
interact with in there.
But the point is that there are
lots of reasons why you as
a web developer might want to
roll your own text editor.
You might want to use
Canvas or WebGL.
Who knows?
The point is that we don't think
you should be limited in
terms of accessibility just
because you want to build a
custom text editor.
So we investigated whether it
was possible to make that
accessible too.
And here's an example.
And let me show you exactly
how it works.
Before I turn on ChromeVox, I'll
just show that this is a
text editor where you can
type things into it.
And it behaves exactly
as you'd expect.
This was all implemented
custom.
It's a lot of work to implement
all the little details.
But it's just normal JavaScript
coding, fun
exercise for the weekend.
Let me turn on ChromeVox and
show you the accessible
experience.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Enabling
spoken feedback.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: Let me--
This is not a text area
or content editable.
It's implemented in
pure JavaScript.
Text box multiline.
This is not a text area
or content editable.
It's implemented in
pure JavaScript.
E-N-T-E-D, implemented.
It's, it's implemented in.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: So I just gave
you a quick demo using
the keyboard to move
through the text.
And you see that ChromeVox
is giving feedback.
That's the exact same feedback
you'd hear if this was a text
area or content editable.
I can make some changes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: In
implemented.
B-U-I-L-T, built, [INAUDIBLE]
using.
[? Roger ?].
X, implemented.
It's built using pure
JavaScript.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: So all the
feedback you'd expect can be
just as accessible to
a screen reader.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Disabling
spoken feedback.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: So how
did we do this?
So in terms of what you need to
do as a web developer, it's
actually not that complicated.
You need to make it focusable.
You give it an ARIA
role of textbox.
And then the important thing
is that you use the native
cursor selection that's already
in your browser's APIs
in order to synchronize the
selection or cursor with
what's seen.
Now, in most browsers there's
no automatic flashing cursor
just in the normal webpage,
if it's not inside a
native input control.
So in this case I built my
own flashing cursor.
But the WebKit selection is
essentially still synchronized
with that same place.
And that's how the assistive
technology knows where the
cursor is so that it can provide
the right feedback.
You don't really need to tell
it anything other than that.
You just need to update the
selection and update the
contents of the text box.
You can use ARIA in there.
You can add objects in there and
give them an ARIA label.
And people can interact
with them.
All sorts of fancy things
you can do.
Now in order to make this
possible, we made some changes
to ChromeVox in order to have
it treat something with a
role=textbox the same way it
would treat content editable.
And it was just a
small change.
And that actually worked
surprisingly well.
And we've been digging
into WebKit and
doing the same thing.
So WebKit based browsers have
the same experience.
And you can try this demo out
with other screen readers and
the latest version of Chrome.
And you'll get a similar
experience.
We wanted to take this
one step further.
Because one of my favorite new
features on the Chromebook and
really Chrome OS and any Chrome
platform in general--
but I really love it on my
Chromebook is that there's now
a Secure Shell application.
That means that right from the
webpage, without switching to
another application, I can open
up a terminal to my Linux
workstation, and compile my
code, and do whatever I need
to do while still browsing
the web right in the same
application.
So it's great on
my Chromebook.
I can use it on the desktop.
And I was wondering if it was
possible to make that
accessible too.
So let me give you a demo
of what that looks like.
I'm just going to open
the app drawer here.
And instead of actually SSHing,
because I don't trust
the network connection here, I'm
going to type [? crosh ?].
Because Chrome OS has
a built-in shell.
And I'm going to access
the local terminal.
Let me turn on ChromeVox
so we can hear some
spoken feedback now.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Enabling
spoken feedback.
Y-T-H-O-N.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: So I'm just
going to run Python.
And I'm going to just give
it a simple math command.
So two--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Two,
s, asterisk.
Asterisk, one, six.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: So two
to the power of 16.
FEMALE SPEAKER: 65,536.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: So you can
see that it's giving me
feedback as I type.
FEMALE SPEAKER: A-s-s-a.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: It's giving me
feedback as I backspace, I
move around.
You can actually run Emacs
or VI and get spoken
feedback for this.
It turns out that this also
wasn't very difficult to do.
Let me go back.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Disabling
spoken feedback.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: It wants to
know that I was going to close
the terminal.
So how does this work?
All you need to do is just like
the previous example with
the custom text box, just
make it focusable.
Now we gave it a role
of textbox.
At some point maybe ARIA will
be extended for another role
for terminal.
Because there's some other
terminal [INAUDIBLE]
emulators out there.
But it turns out that with
just a couple of extra
heuristics to handle the types
of things that happen in a
terminal, we were able to
get ChromeVox to speak
things the same way.
So we think this
is really cool.
So now on any Chromebook, you
can open up the Secure Shell
application and get an
accessible shell experience
with all the spoken feedback
you'd expect.
So at this point, I'm going to
turn it over to Charles, where
he's going to talk about taking
things in the next
level, from just accessible,
to really
usable for power users.
CHARLES CHEN: Thanks, Dominic.
So, Rachel and Dominic here
both gave some really
excellent advice on how to make
your web app accessible.
But what happens if you do all
this work, and you've made it
so that a screen reader can
do a faithful audio
representation of your web
content to the user, but in
doing so it becomes tedious
for frequent users who use
your app hours and
hours every day?
Because if a user has used your
app very frequently, they
know the layout.
Sometimes if you give them too
much information, and you give
it to them for every single
instance of it, it can get
repetitive.
It can get slow.
It actually bogs them down.
So let me show an
example of that.
So I'm actually going
to show Google+.
So, [? strings ?] on Google+
are accessible.
It is a very faithful audio
representation of what a side
user would see on the screen.
But sometimes it can be
a little bit much.
So without further ado, I'm
going to jump into that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Enabling
spoken feedback.
Options menu.
CHARLES CHEN: OK.
Let's go through a couple
of posts here.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Options menu
Larry Page, June 27, 2012,
1:39, 58 PM, edited June
27, 2012, 1:55,
12 PM, sharing details.
I've been having great fun
using our new Nexus seven
tablet announced today.
It's amazing, only $199, and
it includes a $25 credit to
the Google Play Store.
It has amazing battery life.
[? It's ?] super fast with 16
total cores, 12 for graphics
and is thin and light.
Shipping mid July.
Order one now at link below in
US, UK, Canada, Australia.
More coming soon.
Also really enjoying all our
other Google I/O conference
announcements and more to come,
com/image Nexus seven
Google Play.
Nexus seven, made
for Google Play.
Plus one this post.
Share this post.
Start a Hangout about
this post.
Activity on this post,
409 comments.
Gregor Adamczyk, June 29,
2012, 6:38 35 AM.
Not in Germany.
Adzikir Iman, June 29,
2012, 10:18, 58 AM.
Wait for Indonesia.
Add comment.
CHARLES CHEN: OK.
Thank you, ARIA.
So as you see here, this is a
very faithful one for one
audio representation of what a
side user sees on the screen.
You see the user name,
Larry Page.
You see the date.
And you see that little circle
up there in the upper right
hand corner?
I'm going to switch back to the
slide so you can see it
more easily.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Disabling
spoken feedback.
CHARLES CHEN: OK.
So I've highlighted that.
So if you see the red
circle in the
upper right hand corner?
That's a options menu.
Now for a side user, it's
not very distracting.
Because it's just up there.
You see it.
I can click on it.
That's cool.
But in order to make that
accessible you have to say
what it is.
That's why at the beginning of
the post it said Options Menu
before it got to any
of the content.
Because that's the first
thing that's up there.
The other thing that you heard
is after Larry's initial post,
you also heard plus one this
post, reshare, start a Hangout
about this post.
And all of these are really
important features and things
that you can do with
this post.
But if you're using Google+ for
several hours each day,
you know that you can do that
for every single post.
So why do you need to hear it
every time it's up there?
And also for a [? side ?]
user, if you look at the
original post that Larry made,
you see that the comments are
a little bit indented,
a little bit off
to side, and smaller.
So you can glance at it.
And you get an idea that yeah,
there are comments there.
Good enough.
You don't really have to
focus on comments or
get into that content.
However if you're presenting all
that information through
spoken feedback, that can be a
little bit overwhelming as we
all just experienced here.
It read all of the menus,
all of the buttons.
And it also read all of the
comments in one shot.
So while that is a very faithful
representation, it's
not necessarily the experience
that a user who has used this
app for a long time would
want to have.
So can we do something that's
a little bit better?
Can we do something that's
streamlined that takes this to
the next level from just being
accessible to be something
that's really useful, really
efficient, and something
that's really fun that
people want to use.
And the answer is yes.
We can do that with ChromeVox
Extensions, which I am pleased
to announce today.
And the way these work is these
are some APIs we've
added to ChromeVox.
So ChromeVox Extension
is really
just a Chrome Extension.
But it has a few extra API calls
to make it play nicely
with ChromeVox.
So the motivation behind this
is that regular Chrome
Extensions are there to help
heavy users of applications
get their work done
more efficiently.
It can help reformat content
so that it's
easier to look through.
It can add additional shortcuts
and ways to simplify
your workflow.
And that's the same motivation
for ChromeVox Extensions.
It's the same idea but applied
to spoken feedback.
So one API that would be
extremely useful right now
would be the Set Speech
for Node API call.
What this call does is, it lets
you take any DOM node on
a page and give ChromeVox a hint
that perhaps the best way
to speak it would actually be
with this set of rules.
And with these rules you can
control the exact message to
be spoken as well as some of the
more subtle aspects such
as intonation, speech,
pitch, and so forth.
You can also use this, of
course, to rearrange how
things get spoken and the order
in which you hear them.
So let's try the same
example again
with the PlusVox extension.
By the way, just a quick
interrupt so
that everyone knows--
the way that I've been
driving Google+ is
with the J and K keys.
These are keyboard shortcuts.
And they are already built
into the Google+ stream.
So I didn't really have to
do that much custom here.
OK.
So I'm going to enable
PlusVox.
I'm going to reload the page.
Let's try that again.
It works better if you
turn on ChromeVox.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Enabling
spoken feedback.
CHARLES CHEN: Now we don't
have to go all
the way down to that.
We can just do any
other posts.
And you'll hear it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Larry Page, June
27, 2012, edited public
Google [? Glass ?] live demo
today via Hangouts, Hi over
San Francisco.
This is why I love working
with +Sergei Brin.
CHARLES CHEN: OK.
So rather than going through the
entire post, this actually
illustrates the point I was
trying to make, which is
notice how now it starts off
directly with the user name
and with the time.
It didn't actually force you to
listen to an Options menu.
Had I let it continue reading,
it would also have not forced
you to hear plus-one this post,
reshare, start a Hangout.
It will also have summarized the
comments by just letting
the user know how many comments
are available.
And then the user can go
through the comments
individually with other built-in
shortcut keys such as
N and P, such as--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Ross
[? Smith ?]
June 27, 2012, first
to comment.
Plus eight.
CHARLES CHEN: Yeah.
Like that.
Because, of course, you always
want to know first post.
So going back to--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Disabling
spoken feedback.
CHARLES CHEN: OK.
So let's see how we did that.
I'm going to go to a
code slide here.
So it's actually
fairly simple.
As I mentioned earlier, Google+
already gives you the
keyboard shortcuts.
It already moves focus
around for you.
So all I really had to do here
was just to rearrange the
content so that it was spoken in
a way that's more sensible
for heavy users of the app who
are already familiar with it.
And we don't really need to
hear all of the content
multiple times.
So what I have here is it
actually boils down to one
really simple method, generate
speech for thread.
So if I see a Google+ thread
getting focus, I
have a focus watcher.
If it is a Google+ thread, what
I do with it is I run
through it.
I extract the content, such as
who the author is, what's the
date and time, the actual
content from the post.
And I do a little bit of
JavaScript to figure out how
many comments there are.
I put that together into
a node description.
And I use the ChromeVox API,
set speech for node, and I
attach it to that purpose.
So when ChromeVox focuses on
it, it sees that there is a
hint there.
And it uses that hint
to speak it.
So you get a much more fluid,
much more fluent experience
that's optimized for heavy users
of your application.
By the way, there are several
other APIs that come in handy.
For example you can call
syncToNode, which lets you
easily synchronize between
ChromeVox's reading position
and where you are
in the web app.
And also there's a click
function, which is really
helpful because it simulates
a mouse click.
So if you call it a click
function, then you can chain
it together several times.
And you can do that
to run through a
workflow very quickly.
There's a full list of API's
that will be available.
So I encourage you to get these
slides from the web.
And you will be able to
see the full list.
And happy hacking.
I look forward to seeing some
really awesome ChromeVox
Extensions.
By the way, just so that we're
clear on this, again, because
these are the same as Chrome
Extensions, so they can apply
both to your own web app or to
any web app that you feel
could benefit from them.
So thank you.
And feel free to ask me
questions if you have any
about this.
And now, moving back
to Dominic to
talk more about APIs.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: Thanks,
Charles.
So for the last section of the
talk here, what I'd like to
talk about are APIs.
Now these are--
I wrote for accessibility.
But they're actually general
purpose APIs that are
available in Chrome and, in most
cases, in other browsers.
And these are APIs that we've
found really useful for
accessibility.
And we've used these as building
blocks to do really
cool things with them.
But they are general purpose.
You can use them for all sorts
of interesting things.
And I'd like to share some of
those so that it might inspire
you to build custom
accessibility extensions or
tools, or build them into your
apps or other things.
So one of the first ones that
I've been following and I'm
really excited about is
CSS3 Filter Effects.
So this doesn't inherently
have anything to do with
accessibility.
It turns out to be really
useful though.
This is a new emerging
W3C standard.
But it's supported in the latest
versions of Chrome.
And it allows you to apply
filters, like color filters
essentially, to just about
anything on the page.
And they apply to everything
that's contained within an
element-- so including
iframes and video.
It's really cool.
The whole page can
be transformed.
You can blur things.
You can invert things.
You can chain them together.
So you can see the bottom
example there, I can invert an
element and then change
the contrast of it.
This is great for low vision
accessibility.
It means that if you've got some
content on the page that
just really does not work for
users with low vision who have
a really hard time with dark
text on a really bright
background, you can just with a
single line of CSS fix that
problem rather than having a
whole custom stylesheet that
readjusts hundreds of colors
throughout your application.
So as an example right here
just by applying this one
filter to the HTML element,
it inverts
everything on the page.
Notice it also inverted
the image.
So you can fix that.
Because thankfully invert
is invertible.
And instead just apply the
filter again to images.
And in this case I wrote it so
that it inverts JPEG images.
Because those tend
to be photos.
You tend to want to see those
in the original form.
But if you notice the logo at
the bottom when I apply this
here, now the photo
looks great.
The logo at the bottom
was still inverted.
I've found that [? tine ?]
tends to work better.
Because PNG and JIF images tend
to be integrated with the
content of the page, whereas
JPEG images tend to be photos.
This is just a heuristic.
But it shows how this simple API
can make it so much easier
to change the contrast, and
invert the colors, and do
other things, and still preserve
photos for your
application.
So we've built this actually
into an extension that is in
the Web Store now.
It's just called
High Contrast.
And it allows you to invert,
or change the contrast, or
change grayscale
on any webpage.
And it will remember that
on a per site basis.
So this is already something
that's popular
with a lot of users.
Because you can customize this
for every single site out
there rather than trying to have
one global setting that
applies to everything.
But this is something you could
do within your own site.
It's something that
you could do with
another custom extension.
It's a cool API that
I'm excited about.
The next one that I want to talk
about really briefly is,
in Chrome there's a Speech
Recognition Extension API.
Now a lot of you may have seen--
if you were at the
keynote last year, one of the
things that was demoed was the
ability to add a speech input
to any text box on a page.
In fact you can just take an
input, add a x-webkit-speech--
and when this is standardized,
all you'll have to do is add
the speech attribute.
And you get a little
microphone icon.
The user can click on that.
And they can speak.
And whatever they speak will
just get added to that box.
And in fact, you can get a
JavaScript callback so you
know when that's succeeded.
And you can do something
dynamically.
But within Chrome, if you want
lower level access, there's an
experimental extension API--
experimental meaning you
can play with it now.
But you can't deliver an
end user application
using this API yet.
Because users would have to turn
on an experimental flag
in order to use it.
The API--
you can read this sort of
from bottom to top here.
You essentially start.
And then you add some
event listeners.
And then those event listeners
get called when speech is
recognized.
And you get a whole list
of hypotheses.
And that allows you to build an
application that's automated.
And that's sort of that idea
I want to demonstrate here.
So say you have an email
application.
Open email from Larry Page.
And you can get back some
results like this.
So the highest confidence one
was, open email from Larry
Page, which is exactly
what I spoke.
But you'll see some other
hypotheses down there, open
email and merry paint.
The cool thing is because you
get all those hypotheses, even
if the first result wasn't
correct, you could do your own
processing to try to guess the
intent of the user or present
the user with some options.
So this is really cool
for accessibility.
This makes it possible just
using pure web technology to
build automation applications
for hands free use, for people
who have poor motor control.
And anyway this is
an exciting API.
And I'm looking forward to
seeing the things that
developers will build
with that.
And then last, I'd like to talk
about the Chrome's Text
to Speech Extension API.
Last year we talked
about this.
And last year this API
was experimental.
But in October this was released
as a stable API for
all developers in Chrome.
There's also a W3C standard
that's in the works.
So at some point this might be
part of the web platform.
It'll be available
in any web page.
You can try it out
in Chrome now.
And there are dozens of talking
applications and
extensions in the Web Store,
including ChromeVox.
But there's talking alarm clocks
and talking notifiers
for your Twitter or your
email, or all sorts
of things like that.
This is obviously really
cool for accessibility.
And I wanted to show
off some of the
things that are possible.
Just to get something to speak
within your application is
really simple.
I've got some code right here.
And I'm just going to eval
that code directly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello, world.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: You can change
the rate if you want it
to speak a little bit faster.
So I'm just going
to change this.
And maybe you want to raise the
pitch a little bit, make
it sound a little
higher pitched.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello, world.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: It's that
easy to make some simple
changes and just to
get some speech.
So if you have a Chrome app or
extension and you want to add
the ability to speak,
it's that easy.
There's also a companion API
called the Chrome Text to
Speech Engine API.
And what that means for end
users is that you can install
a new voice with just a click
from the Chrome Web Store.
And that new voice intercepts
calls to the text to speech
speed call.
And then it can use any HTML
technique out there in order
to actually generate
that speech.
So an example of it looks
just like this.
This is the extent of the API.
You just register speak and stop
listeners and then send
events back as things happen.
Now how would you actually
implement a voice?
Well if you have speech on some
remote server, you could
generate the speech
on a remote server
and stream that down.
You could do it using
pure JavaScript.
If you were at one of the other
talks about HTML5 audio
APIs, they're really
sophisticated.
There's a really cool demo out
there of generating speech
using pure JavaScript.
But our preferred solution is
Native Client, where you can
take a high quality speech
engine written at a lower
level languages like C++,
compile that down to Native
code that's securely run in the
Native Client sandbox, so
that it'll run on any platform
with a safe user click so that
users don't have to worry about
Native code that might
have security exploits
or something in it.
So in fact I'd like to introduce
a new text to speech
engine that's available
for download now.
It's the one you've
been listening to.
This is the same speech engine
that's being used in Android.
So if you all saw the keynote
with the new Voice Search
feature in Android and you heard
that voice, that voice
is actually available
to you to run on
the client in Chrome.
You can go to the Web Store and
download the US English
female Text to Speech by Google,
and install that.
And now all of your Chrome apps
and extensions have that
voice available.
It's fast.
It's high quality.
You can turn up the rate of
speed really fast for
accessibility.
But it's also really clear
and understandable.
I wouldn't recommend running in
on lower end hardware yet.
Need to do some work
to optimize that.
It's kind of memory hungry.
But there's some other speech
engines out there.
But we're really excited to
introduce this not only as a
great option for accessibility
and for other applications,
but as a really cool demo of
what's possible with Chrome
Extensions and Native Client.
So my favorite feature and just
one more thing I'd like
to add here is that not only can
you generate speech, but
you get real time feedback from
most speech engines on
exactly what's taking place, so
you know when it's speaking
each word in the stream.
And that allows you to
synchronize things and do
really cool things.
So I built a little demo
of that like that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Far out in the
uncharted backwaters of the
unfashionable end of the Western
Spiral arm of the
Galaxy lies a small unregarded
yellow sun.
Orbiting this at a distance of
roughly 98 million miles is an
utterly insignificant little
blue green planet whose ape
descended life forms are so
amazingly primitive that they
still think digital watches
are a pretty neat idea.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: So credit
Douglas Adams for
the quote, of course.
Rachel.
RACHEL SHEARER: That
was really awesome.
I wish I could read all my books
or have all my books
read to me over a spiral
galaxy floating around.
That's awesome.
So I'm back.
I'm going to do a recap of what
you just heard over the
course of the talk.
So at the beginning, if you
remember, I talked about tools
to help you find and eliminate
accessibility errors,
including the new Accessibility
Developer Tools extension.
And then Dominic talked about
advanced accessibility
techniques, like an accessible
text editor,
an accessible terminal.
And then Charles talked about
ChromeVox Extensions and
actually showed PlusVox for
the first time to anybody,
which was really neat.
And then finally Dominic came
on back and showed his
favorite accessibility APIs,
like CSS3 filters, Chrome
Speech Recognition,
Chrome TTS, and
the Chroms TTS Engine.
I'm not really sure which one
of those is his favorite.
But I think he loves them all.
So that's what we've
talked about today.
This last slide has links to
some resources that can help
you in your quest to
build better, more
accessible web apps.
And I also wanted to finish
with a final thought.
Up on the stage, we've been
really excited to talk to you
about these tools and techniques
and APIs that help
us, and we think can help you,
make your web applications
more accessible.
But today isn't just about us.
It's about you.
We can't wait to see what
you're going to
do with these tools.
Accessibility is partly an
exciting field because a lot
of these problems aren't
solved yet.
And we're hoping that you in
this audience, with the tools
that we're so excited to show
to you, can work on solving
these problems.
So we can't wait to see what
you're going to do.
Thank you very much.
We'd be happy to
take questions.
AUDIENCE: You showed some APIs
that were interesting around
the ability to control
what text is
actually read for a node.
CHARLES CHEN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is that just
extensions, only available to
extensions?
CHARLES CHEN: No.
No.
That's an excellent point.
And no, it's not.
If you have your own web
app, you can also use
that same API call.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So is that a proprietary
thing?
Or is there a standards
check for that?
CHARLES CHEN: So right now this
is an experimental thing.
We want to see how well
this works out.
But right now we're
experimenting with it in ChromVox.
And it is a ChromeVox
Extension API--
DOMINIC MAZZONI: That's right.
CHARLES CHEN: That's available
to web apps and to extensions.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: And if you're
interested in standards, I
know that the ARIA committee has
just started taking ideas
for ARIA 2.0.
And this is at the top of the
list of things that we want to
propose there and turn
that into a standard.
But this is sort of our
opportunity to experiment,
figure out how the API might
work, and what we need for the
apps that we want to build.
CHARLES CHEN: So if you think
it's cool, I encourage you to
build something awesome with it
and help bolster the case
for why it should be there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Simple question-- the
Accessibility Developer Tools
I saw requires Chrome 21.
My usual developer build link
for Mac is still Chrome 20.
Is there any good
way to get 21?
Or do you know if it
will come soon?
DOMINIC MAZZONI: 21 is the
current Dev Channel.
So if you're on Dev Channel--
the other thing I'd recommend
as a developer if you want to
try cutting edge stuff, but
you don't want to mess up your
everyday browser, download
Chrome Canary.
Chrome Canary is the very
latest-- it's like a nightly
build of Chrome.
It updates nightly.
But it has a separate profile.
So it won't mess up your
normal browser.
So that's what I use when I
want to try out the latest
cutting edge extensions
and APIs.
But if it crashes, it's not
going to mess up my everyday
email and things I really
need to do.
RACHEL SHEARER: Another thing
I want to add is that
Developer Tools extensions
in general do require an
experimental extension API.
So you'll have to set that in
Chrome Flags before you can
use the Accessibility
Developer Tools.
Hopefully that'll make it out
of experimental soon.
But for now that's what
you have to do.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans to
create these extensions in
different languages?
DOMINIC MAZZONI: Can you be
a little more specific?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The extension you with the
female voice to create
extensions in multi-languages.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: Yeah.
So the API fully supports
multiple languages.
When you ask it to speak the
default is whatever language
your browser is set to as
its default language.
But you can pass a language
parameter in.
If you have multiple voices
installed, it will pick the
voice of the correct language.
Google has released voices in
English on the Web Store.
I can't say what
our plans are.
But the API is open for third
party developers to introduce
other voices.
If you have a Windows or a Mac
computer, there's built in
speech in several languages.
And the API already works
with those languages.
So if you tell it to speak,
anyone on Windows and Mac, as
long as they have the voice
provided by the operating
system or that they've
installed, it'll speak using
those languages too.
CHARLES CHEN: Also I'd like to
add that on Chrome OS, we do
have EFIGS.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: Oh, that's
a good point.
Yeah.
RACHEL SHEARER: French, Italian,
German, Spanish.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: That's right.
So all of those work out of
the box on Chrome OS.
RACHEL SHEARER: Anybody else?
Don't be shy.
AUDIENCE: Are you using any
guidelines for the tests that
you're applying in the
Accessibility Tools, like WCAG
for example.
RACHEL SHEARER: So if you go
to the wiki, the links that
are inside the Developer
Tools, there's more
information about what
guidelines we're following.
As I said in the talk, we
really want to emphasize
practical accessibility and
simple errors that we can do a
good job of testing.
So it's more fully
explained there.
But for contrast ratio, for
example, we are using the WCAG
contrast ratio.
For other stuff we're kind of
pulling from what we think
would make the best experience
for a user.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: Yeah.
So whenever possible, our
goal is to reference
all the right standards.
And so we looked through
everything in WCAG that seemed
appropriate.
But our primary goal was just
practical web accessibility.
So if there was something that
was too hard to detect or we
didn't think was necessarily
good advice in general, we
biased things in favor of what
we think was practical and
useful for users today.
RACHEL SHEARER: I definitely
want to say Accessibility
Developer Tools is not a
replacement for the testing
that you might be doing as
a web app developer.
We see it as kind of an easy way
to get a good idea of how
your app is doing.
But if you have special
accessibility testing that you
do otherwise, you should
continue to do that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Daniel.
Great session again.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You showed the way to
invert the whole page and
to take out certain
images like that.
Is there a similar way to do
something for people who are
red-green blind?
DOMINIC MAZZONI: That's
a great question.
So there is a spec
for that now.
And the spec--
if you know OpenGL, it's
actually a way to specify a
pixel shader that it gets
applied to the whole webpage,
which is really awesome
and powerful.
As far as I know that hasn't
been implemented in any
browser yet.
But there are people working
on it for WebKit.
Some of the code's already
checked in.
If you want to recompile
WebKit yourself, you
can play with it.
But it's not available in any
shipping browser yet.
I'm really looking forward
to using that.
Because with a pixel shader,
you can apply all sorts of
crazy effects to everything
on the page.
RACHEL SHEARER: If there is
no other questions, I
guess that's it.
Thank you all for coming.
And we'll be around afterwards,
probably just
outside if you want to talk
to us individually.
Thank you very much.
DOMINIC MAZZONI: Thanks again,
CHARLES CHEN: Thanks.